a million questions for you but you got
to I don't want to do any spoilers but
you got to include nods in the first six
episodes two things from the past yes
and I'm and I'm curious were there was
there anything that you really wanted to
include as like a nod to something from
the past that you just couldn't figure
out how to work it in
uh no no not really
um there are characters that I wish
could uh could appear but might be
appearing on other Star Trek shows
um and you know you don't want to over
saturate uh the Universe
um but for the most part I I was I
couldn't believe I got away with what I
got away with uh the uh especially when
you see the last four there's there's
more to come uh that uh but I think the
most important part is if it hopefully
and I hope you felt it is that it feels
organic you know specifically episode
six we go to some locations that are
rich with Star Trek history and so
there's a fine line between
fan service and just being in the
universe in which
50 years of History exist and if you
don't take a moment and reference it and
have a little fun what are you even
doing
um so it's it's hard it's it's a
difficult thing but we we feel like we
got to do almost everything we wanted to
do what was it like actually uh coming
up with the finale because this could be
the last time all these characters are
depicted together on screen I mean this
could be the end yes I can't really talk
about it too much but I don't I will
tell you that uh uh I think it's
satisfying I think when you get there
and you realize when you see the whole
picture
and the puzzle comes together
um it it feels like a satisfying
conclusion of Star Trek the Next
Generation however it also is a passing
of the torch
but the last generation to the Next
Generation and that there are some new
characters you might want to see
continue and some new Starships you
might want to continue to see boldly go
into the final frontier
so uh it yeah well my thing is that I
was wondering when you're doing
something like this and you're writing
the finale of you know Picard season
three how who is actually the person at
the studio that you're sort of like who
was the person you were saying this is
what I want to do is this okay I was
very fortunate uh particularly with this
season that they kind of let me do my
own thing yeah uh it is not a common
experience but I was I would I I had a
lot of trust uh given to me uh by uh it
was lovely uh by everyone involved
um and uh uh
I I can't I I could not be more
appreciative of that
um and I and again I could have it could
be a complete failure fans could have
been like what did he do he just made
this mess of a thing
um but uh yeah there were moments when I
had to call and say I'm gonna bring
flying this guy from New York he played
Professor Moriarty he played who he
played Professor Moriarty is an
important part of Star Trek history all
right look we're gonna trust you it's
you're playing for flights you're paying
trust me
it's it's important to the DNA of who
these characters are so and they did
um and certainly others as as you've
seen looking at in the in the first six
there are there's there's
others that are meaningful
um and it's pretty great when
um the powers that be are like okay you
you say so
well I'm I have to rap but I'm just
gonna say I'm glad you understand Trek's
history and could incorporate thank you
are you a big transformers fan uh I I
have been known to enjoy some
Transformers the original 1986 movie
uh actually yes okay well then you
should drop into my DMC if you can find
the reference in season three to that
movie I now will be looking at it in a
new way thank you so much and uh
congrats on the success thank you so
much it means a lot to me that you like
it really does I really did I'll talk to
you soon